the org next on book TV Tom Englehart
creator and editor of Tom dispatch calm
argues that the US government
successfully used the threat of
terrorism to scare the public into
supporting increased spending on war the
military and homeland security this is
about an hour forty minutes
well welcome everyone I am but before I
introduce Tom Engelhardt I just wanted
to say that I am a very proud supporter
of Haymarket books you know there's that
old saying that the that the press is
only free if you own one and when
Haymarket was created it really was like
the people had a press to do stories to
tell stories and to produce books that
had a social justice focus that were not
interested in in a trickle-down telling
of history but a rising up telling of
history and I think it's it's very
fitting that someone like Tom engelhardt
would be publishing with Haymarket books
because it really is a match made in
rebellion you know for four years I
actually thought Tom englehart's name
was Tom dispatch because he to this
wonderful newsletter that was it was
covering the issues of the day but
covering them in a way that was totally
anathema to the way the corporate media
functions in this society getting in
depth
tapping experts highlighting
whistleblowers analyzing US policy
without regard to partisan
considerations and I think that Tom
Dispatch is is some of the best we have
to offer in this country in terms of
citizen journalism and journalism the
challenges not only a corp autocracy or
or a sort of duopoly but also challenges
corporate media outlets on their own
turf and I think it's if you haven't
heard of Tom dispatch or have signed up
for that newsletter you most certainly
should but of course his name is not Tom
dispatch his name is Tom engelhardt and
his the book that we're here to
celebrate tonight is the United States
of fear I had the honor of helping Tom
launch his last book the American Way of
war and I you know I generally don't
like it when authors read from their
books I would rather just hear them talk
I was I was so just taken with the
passion of Tom angle heart when he was
reading from his last book I'm very
excited to hear him read a couple of
excerpts from his current book beyond
being a great writer tom is an
incredible editor and he's edited books
that probably many of you in this room
have read through the American Empire
series of metropolitan books he
did noam chomsky Chalmers Johnson Andrew
bacevich some of the leading dissident
minds in the United States if if we
lived in a more sane reality the mind of
Tom angle heart would be tapped by the
national security apparatus to actually
help analyze what US policy should be
around the world and let's be clear
about this we live in a very dark moment
in history where the United States is
simultaneously waging covert wars over
at Wars air wars drone wars economic
wars on multiple continents and in
scores of countries around the world the
u.s. announced and there was much
fanfare about the the end of the Iraq
war and yet we see Iraq descending
further and further into chaos and the
United States has this massive embassy
there and is actually increasing the
number of private contractors that are
going to be operating in Iraq as the
official US military withdraws in
Afghanistan the United States is
increasingly moving toward a front and
centering of the most lethal forces in
the u.s. arsenal those from the Special
Operations Command the Joint Special
Operations Command all of America heard
about the Joint Special Operations
Command and SEAL Team six because of the
targeted assassination of Osama bin
Laden but actually the Joint Special
Operations Command has been around for a
long time and has been at the heart of
some of the most lethal operations that
the US has carried out in declared
battlefields and in undeclared
battlefields and we're going to be
hearing a lot more from them in
Afghanistan because they're the lead
force in doing the night raids and and
that is the the premier policy right now
around the world is believing that there
are a finite number of bad guys that
simply need to be killed and this this
problem is going to be solved I just
returned from a two-week reporting trip
in Yemen where the United States has
been increasing its bombing in that
country not just through drones but also
through Tomahawk cruise missiles and
cluster bombs and I assure you that the
civilians that are being killed in these
bombings are fueling a rage that will be
very very difficult to stamp out later
down the line in Somalia where I was a
few months ago the United States is
backing
warlords including some of some of them
who were key al-qaida allies at another
point in their life and those that
helped to destroy Somalia in the first
place in the early 1990s the United
States continues to be involved with
secret prisons including in Somalia in
Mogadishu in Pakistan u.s. raids into
Pakistan continued relations are
deteriorating between the u.s. and
Pakistan because of these raids and
terrorism or the the perceived threat of
terrorism seems to be expanding in
countries where the u.s. claims to be
trying to stamp it out those two
realities cannot be seen as separate
from each other we have to come to grips
with the possibility I would say the
reality that US policy is actually
fuelling terrorism but also giving
people a justifiable reason to be angry
at the United States and in all of the
countries I've been traveling to in the
past two years I've seen that in a very
very clear way and one of the sources
that I go to for serious analysis for
people who are going to think outside of
the box of conventional Washington
thinking I sound like Mitt Romney but
outside of the box of convention I am I
am definitely not a Washington insider
one of the one of the places that I go
regularly to read serious analysis and
and to be provoked in a very good way is
Tom dispatch and the work of Tom angle
hearten so please join me in giving a
hearty welcome to the author of the
united states of fear tom englehart's
well Jeremy's kind of a stand-up guy and
I'm kind of a stand down guy I'm an
editor and it's rare in my life that I'm
in front of any group of people like
this so I'm a little relieved that I
have something to read before we get to
spontaneity I'm assuming since I'm here
in the Arthur L Carter journalism
Institute that some of you are actually
young journalists or journalists to be
and of course I'm about to have a
conversation with an investigative
journalist who gets out there on the
ground and the hairiest of places and
regularly comes back with the goods I'm
impressed
I'm always impressed with great
reporters I've been a news jockey since
I was a kid and while I spend time
endlessly online I still read my
hometown paper daily or nightly in print
I love the generosity of journalists by
which I mean their willingness to go
places I wouldn't or couldn't go and
bring back experiences and worlds I
couldn't otherwise I
I would otherwise have no way of
entering and when I speak about
reportorial generosity for the best of
journalists anyway I'm also referring to
their skill and entering the world I
live in everyday and resting from its
stories I hadn't even imagined were
there in my life I've known journalists
as a book editor and now as the guy who
does the website Tom dispatch calm I
published their work and for years I
taught journalism graduate students
every spring at the University of
California Berkeley for a few years in
my life long long long ago I even worked
at a small West Coast news service but
just to be clear these days when someone
refers to me as a journalist I always
deny it if pressed as to what I consider
myself to be I usually say that
professionally speaking I'm a guy in a
room which is of course a literal
description of the essence of my life
and by the way I don't mean it as a
put-down I say it with some pride I mean
if you think about it Jon Stewart is
also just a guy in a room admittedly
he's got one heck of a room and he's al
awful lot funnier than I am but still
the fact is in our world which is often
remarkably stifling when it comes to
thinking about writing about about our
politics about the national security
state about what used to be called for
policy but is now more accurately
thought of as global military policy we
definitely need some guys in rooms even
when as with me the rooms are very very
small
we need people willing to try to step
back ready to try to make their way out
of the mass of trees and actually take
in the woods were largely lost in my
book the United States of fear is really
what one guy in such a room could
produce in a year of reading writing
talking and doing my best to consider
our American world and the absurdities
in it that are accepted as ordinary
reality as those of you who read Tom
dispatch know I write long myself and I
like to run long framework style pieces
at the site by others that is despite
what everyone thinks about brevity
attention spans in the internet before
Jeremy and I talk I'm going to read you
two pieces from the book both however on
the shorter side the first as you'll see
is really my thoughts about guys and
rooms
I wrote it back in March 2010 well
before our military was out of Iraq and
just after the Supreme Court issued its
Citizens United decision but before it
was utterly clear that the floodgates
had been opened so wide that what might
be called the politics of the rich in
America would soon become simply
American politics I called it on being a
critic all the world's a stage for us in
March 2010 I wrote about a group of
pundits and warrior journalists eager
not to see the US military leave Iraq
that piece appeared on the op-ed page of
the Los Angeles Times and at a longer
version at Tom dispatch calm and then
began wandering the media world one of
its stops curiously enough was the
military newspaper Stars and Stripes
from a military man came this emailed
response read your article in Stars and
Stripes when was the last time you
visited Iraq a critique and 15
well-chosen words so much more effective
than the usual long angry emails I get
and his point was interesting at least
it interested me after all as I wrote
back I was then a 65 year old guy who
had never been anywhere near Iraq
and undoubtedly never would be I have to
assume that my emailer
had spent some had spent time there
possibly more than once and disagreed
with my assessments firsthand experience
is not to be taken lightly
what after all do I know about Iraq only
the reporting I've been able to read
from thousands of miles away or at or
analysis found on the blogs of experts
like Juan Cole on the other hand even
from thousands of miles away I was one
of many who could see and enough by
early 2003 to go into the streets and
demonstrate against an unrest a stir of
an invasion that a lot of people
theoretically far more knowledgeable on
Iraq than any of us considered just the
cat's meow the cakewalk of the new
century it's true that I've never
strolled down a street in Baghdad or
Ramadi or Basra armed or not and that's
a deficit if you want to write about the
American experience in Iraq it's also
true that I haven't spent hours sipping
tea with Iraqi tribal leaders or been
inside the green zone or set foot on
even one of the vast American bases that
the Pentagon's private contractors built
in that country nor did that stop me
from writing regularly about what I
called and still call America's
ziggurats when most of the people who
visited those bases didn't consider
places with 20-mile perimeters multiple
bus lines px is familiar fast-food
franchises Ugandan mercenary guards and
who knows what else to be particularly
noteworthy structures on the Iraqi
landscape and so with rare exceptions
worth commenting on I'm certainly no
expert on Shiites and Sunnis I'm
probably a little foggy on my Iraqi
geography and I've never seen the
tigress or Euphrates rivers on the other
hand it does occur to me that a whole
raft of American pundits government
officials and military types who have
done all of the above who have spent
time up close and personal in Iraq or at
least in the American version of the
same couldn't have arrived at Dumber
conclusions over these last many years
so first hand experience valuable as it
may be for great reporters like say
Anthony Shadid of the Washington Post
and now the New York Times or Patrick
Coburn if the British independent
can't be the be-all and the end-all
either sometimes being
far away not just from Iraq but from
Washington and all the cloistered
thinking that goes on there from the
visibly claustrophobic world of American
global policymaking has its advantages
sometimes being out of it experientially
speaking allows you to open your eyes
and take in the larger shape of things
which is often the obvious even if
little noted I can't help thinking about
a friend of mine who's up close and
personal take on US military commanders
in Afghanistan was that they were
trapped in an american-made box
incapable of seeing beyond its
boundaries of that is seeing Afghanistan
I have no doubt that being there is
generally something to be desired
but if you take your personal blinders
with you it often hardly matters where
you are thinking about my stars and
stripes readers question the conclusion
I'd provisionally come to is this it's
not just where you go it's also how you
see what's there and no less important
who you see that matters which means
that sometimes you can actually see more
by going nowhere at all
an Iraqi tragedy when American officials
civilian or military open their eyes and
check out the local landscape no matter
where they've landed all evidence
indicates that the first thing they tend
to see is themselves that is they see
the world as an American stage and those
native actors and countries we've
invaded and occupied or where as in
Pakistan Somalia and Yemen we conduct
what might be called semi war as so many
bit players in an American drama this is
why in both Iraq and Afghanistan
military commanders and top officials
like Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
or national security adviser James Jones
continued to call so utterly
unselfconsciously for putting an Iraqi
or Afghan face on whichever war was
being discussed that is to follow the
image to its logical conclusion
putting an Iraqi or Afghan mask over a
face that they recognize however
inconveniently
or embarrassingly as American this is
why American officials regularly say
that Afghans are in the lead when they
aren't but this is why when you read
newspaper descriptions of how the United
States is giving Afghan
president hamid karzai the leading role
in deciding about the latest military
offensive or pushing such-and-such an
official with his US or western mentors
in the wings to take the lead in some
action that seems to have been largely
planned by Americans the Afghan sound
like so many puppets which doesn't
actually mean that they are and this
doesn't embarrass Americans in the least
generally speaking the American post
9/11 language of power ostensibly aimed
at building up the forces Washington
supports in Muslim lands invariably
sounds condescending
they are always peripheral to us even
when they are being urged or prodded to
be at the center of the action this is
why they're civilians who come in harm's
way are referred to as collateral damage
an inconceivable way to describe
American civilians in harm's way this is
why from the Vietnam era to today in the
movies that are made about our Wars even
the anti-war ones Americans invariably
hug center stage well you usually have
to keep a careful watch to find passing
evidence of those we are fighting
against or for this was why 40 years ago
the Vietnam War was regularly referred
to here
whether by Hawks or doves as an American
tragedy not a Vietnamese one and why the
same thinking applies to Afghanistan and
Iraq today this is why using imagery
that might have come out of the mouths
of nineteenth-century colonialists
American officials long talk
patronizingly about teaching the Iraqi
child to pedal the bike of democracy
with us as global parents holding on to
the bike seat Donald Rumsfeld the
Secretary of Defense did this very
vividly it's just stays in my mind this
is the context within which even a
president and this was President Bush
wondered when to take off the training
wheels
this is evidently why today the
introduction of democracy to Iraq is
considered an American gift so precious
that it somehow makes up for anything
that's happened in the past eight years
this is why for instance pundit Tom
Friedman could write this sentence about
the u.s. prospect project in Iraq former
president george w bush's gut instinct
that this region craved and needed
democracy was always right
like Afghanistan before it Iraq is now
largely the Forgotten War and here that
is and here's a little of what's been
forgotten in the process of what
Friedman suggests he'd prefer to leave
future historians to sort out that the
American invasion led to possibly
hundreds of thousands of Iraqi deaths
that literally millions of Iraqis had to
flee into exile abroad and millions more
were turned into refugees in their own
country that the capital Baghdad was
significantly ethnically cleansed in a
brutal Shiite Sunni civil conflict that
the country was littered with new
killing fields that a devastating
insurgency roiled the land and still
brings enough death and terror to
Baghdad to make it one of the more
dangerous places on the planet that a
soaring unemployment rate and lack of
delivery of the most basic services
including reliable electricity and
potable water created nightmarish
conditions for a vast class of
impoverished Iraqis that the US
government for all its nation-building
boasts proved remarkably incapable of
reconstructing the country or its oil
industry even though American private
contractors profited enormous Lee from
work on both that a full-scale foreign
military occupation left Americans on
five hundred bases nationwide and in the
largest embassy on the planet the pride
of us in other words as bad as Saddam
Hussein was and he was a megalomaniac
'el monster what followed him was a
staggering catastrophe for Iraq even if
Americans no longer care to give it much
thought
against the charnel house that Friedman
would prefer to leave to history however
stands one counterbalancing factor the
gift of democracy even many who never
supported george w bush is a democracy
agenda now seemed to take some pride in
this let's leave aside for a moment the
fact that the Bush administration
arrived in a room at in Iraq with
remarkably undemocratic plans for the
country and was thwarted only by the
unwavering insistence of the revered
Shiite cleric Ali Sistani on a
one-person one-vote election in all of
this there are staggering levels of
hypocrisy in the fact that we were for
Saddam before we were against him in the
fact as well that the u.s. government
has
in instance after instance regularly
fostered and supported military hunters
strongmen and dictators while holding
off or overthrowing democracies not to
our taste or not in what Washington
defined as our untrue interests
perhaps stranger yet the democracy that
we actually have in the United States
and so can offer is our ultimate apology
for invading and occupying other
countries is rarely subjected to
analysis in the context of the glorious
urge to export the same so let's stop
for a moment and think a little about
the American urge to be thrilled that
despite every disaster against all odds
our grand accomplishment lies in
bringing American democracy to Iraq the
rectification of names
democracy like terrorism is a method a
means to an end not an end in itself
nobody is ruled by elections any more
than any organization is run by terror
or as terrorists as ultimate goal
if this obvious point had been accepted
in the wake of 99 11 attacks the
absurdity of the idea of a global war on
terror would have been self-evident as
would a global war to deliver democracy
to faraway people's democracy after all
is a way to determine and then Express
the majoritarian will of a people a way
to deliver power to the people or more
important for those people to take
possession of it themselves it's the
sort of thing that by its nature is hard
to import from great distances
especially when as in our case the
delivery system to be exported seems
strikingly deficient and keep in mind
that the people exporting that system to
Iraq were largely incapable of seeing
the Iraqis as actors in their own
Democratic drama they were incapable
that is of imagining the nature of the
lives they wanted to shape and change in
a sense that was hardly less true when
they looked homeward after all the
glorious democracy they trumpeted to the
world were little relation to the packs
and republicana headed by an imperial
presidency complete with a cult of
executive power that they dreamed of
installing in Washington for generations
to come
given the nature of American democracy
today the first billion dollar
presidential election the staggering
levels of lobbying and influence
peddling that go with it the stunning
mirages of bizarre advertising the
increasingly corporate owned and
financed campaigns a half broken
congressional system a national security
state with unparalleled powers and money
and so on why all the effort to take it
to Iraq why measure Iraqis against it
and find them lacking after all in 2000
our presidential election went to the
non majoritarian candidate thanks to the
decisions made thanks to decisions made
by Supreme Court justices appointed by
his father if this had happened in
Nigeria Afghanistan or perhaps Iraq we
would know just what we were dealing
with the fact is we have no word to
adequately describe what at the national
level we still persist in calling
democracy what we regularly ask others
to admire to the skies or bow down
before in Imperial China when a new
dynasty arrived on the scene the Emperor
performed a ritual called
the rectification of names in the belief
that the previous dynasty had fallen in
part because reality and the names we
have for it we the names they had for it
had ceased to correspond we in the
United States undoubtedly now needs such
a ceremony we certainly need a new term
for our own democracy before we're so
quick to hold it up as the paragon for
others to match we also need to rethink
our language when it comes to the u.s.
military undertaking nation-building and
distant lands as if the countries as if
countries could be constructed to our
taste in just the way that KBR or
DynCorp construct military bases in them
so no I have never been to Iraq but yes
I've been here for years watching and I
can see among other things that the
American mirror on the wall which shows
us ourselves in such beautiful
disney-esque detail has a few cracks in
it it looks fragile I'd think twice
about sending it abroad too often now
for my second reading tonight I chose a
personal piece about a subject that's
been in the news repeatedly in recent
years but only in the strangest and most
limited of ways one of the bizarre
spectacles of our American moment has
been this nuclear weapons and nuclear
politics only manifests themselves in
one fashion in our news and what passes
for popular discussion punditry and
political debate I'm talking of course
about the Iranian bomb the one that we
can't stop yakking about writing about
beating the war drums over warning about
or fretting over almost daily the one
that doesn't exist it's the nuclear
weapon that isn't there is no evidence
that the Iranians are moving to build
nuclear weapons at the moment at worst
our intelligence services suggest that
they are moving toward what's called
breakout capacity the ability to build a
weapon relatively quickly if a decision
to do so were made nonetheless this is
the only nuclear weapon in the world
other than in brief moments the
perfectly real North Korean ones that
get any significant attention the United
States at last count possesses 5113
nuclear warheads Russia similar
thousands about ourselves as about the
Russians or the Israelis who probably
have a couple of hundred and they're
undeclared but all too real arsenal we
evidently have no doubts or worries we
certainly trust ourselves implicitly
though we are of course the only country
ever to use such weapons the recent
Pentagon budget cuts and you'd have to
put that word cuts in quotes as of now
involve no cuts to our nuclear arsenal
the actual money's going into it are in
fact on the rise and about it no one
demands anything no one panics no one
thinks about going to war nor do we fret
about say the Indian nuclear arsenal
who's further development Washington has
aided and abetted even though the South
Asian subcontinent is probably the place
on the planet where nuclear weapons are
most likely to be used in any case with
all that in mind and given the fact that
from childhood I've had what we used to
call the bomb and we put it in caps on
the brain I thought I would read this
piece tonight which I wrote as another
August Hiroshima anniversary rolled
around it's called the nuclear story
that refuses to go away even though we
promptly dubbed the site of the 9/11
attacks in New York
zero once a term reserved for the atomic
blast Americans have never really come
to grips either with the atomic bombings
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki or with the
nuclear age that they ushered in there
can be no question that as the Big Bang
that might end it all
the atomic bomb haunted Cold War America
in those years while the young myself
included watched endless versions of
nuclear disaster transmuted into be
horror films the grownups who ran our
world went on a vast shopping spree for
world-ending weaponry building nuclear
arsenals that came to number in the tens
of thousands when the Cold War finally
ended with the Soviet Union's quite
peaceful collapse however a nuclear
peace dividend never quite arrived the
Arsenal's of the former superpower
adversaries remained quietly in place
drawn down but strangely untouched
awaiting a new mission well just beyond
sight the knowledge of the making of
such weapons spread to other countries
ready to launch their own threatening
mini Cold War's even 50 years after that
first bomb went off over Hiroshima it's
still proved impossible in the United
States to agree upon a nuclear creation
tale was August 6 1945 the heroic ending
to a global war or the horrific
beginning of a new age the Enola Gay the
plane that dropped the Hiroshima bomb
and a shattered children and it
shattered school child's lunchbox from
hiroshima could not yet it turned out
inhabit the same exhibit space of the
Smithsonian's National Air and Space
Museum in Washington DC still four
people of a certain age like me
Hiroshima is where it all began so I
would like to try once again to lay out
the pieces of a nuclear story that none
of us it seems can yet quite tell in my
story there are three characters in no
dialogue there is my father who
volunteered at age 35 for the Army Air
Corps
immediately after the Japanese attack on
Pearl Harbor he fought in Burma was
painfully silent on his wartime
experiences and died on Pearl Harbor day
in 1983 then there's me growing up in a
world in which my father's war was
glorified everywhere in which my Play
fantasies in any park included
mowing down Japanese soldiers but whose
nightmares were of nuclear destruction
finally there is a Japanese boy whose
name and fate are unknown to me this is
a story of multiple silences the first
of those the silence of my father was
once no barrier to the stories I told
myself if anything his silence enhanced
them since in the 1950s mail silence
seemed a heroic attribute and perhaps it
was though hardly in the way I imagined
at the time sitting in the dark with him
then at any World War two movie was
enough for me as it turned out though
the only part of his war I possessed was
its final act and around this too there
grew of puzzling silence the very idea
of nuclear destruction seemed not to
touch him
like other schoolchildren I went through
nuclear tack drills with sirens howling
outside while I had no doubt he
continued to work unfazed in his office
it was I who watched the irradiated ants
and nuclearized monsters of our teen 18
screen lifes stomped the earth it was I
who went to the french film hiroshima
mon amour where i was shocked by my
first sight of the human casualties of
the a bombing and two on the beach to
catch a glimpse of how the world might
actually end it was I who saw the
mushroom cloud rise in my dreams felt
its heat sear my arm before I awoke of
all this I said not a word to him nor he
to me on his erstwhile enemies however
my father was not silent he hated the
Japanese with a war bred passion they
had he told me done things that could
not be discussed to boys he had known
subsequent history the amicable American
occupation of Japan or the emergence of
that defeated land as an ally did not
seem to touch him his hatred of all
things Japanese was not a ruling passion
of my childhood but only because Japan
was so absent from our lives
there was nothing Japanese in our house
one did not buy their products we
avoided the only Japanese restaurant in
our part of town and no Japanese ever
came to visit in the end I followed my
own path to Hiroshima drawn perhaps to
the world my father had Soviet Lee
rejected vehemently rejected in 1917
as an editor I published unforgettable
fire the drawings of Hiroshima residents
who had lived through that day the first
time any sizable number of images of the
human damage there made it into
mainstream American culture I visited
Japan in 1982 thanks to the books
Japanese editor who took me to Hiroshima
an experience I found myself unable to
talk about on return this too became
part of the silences my father and I
shared to make a story thus far would
seem relatively simple two generations
faced each other across the chasm of the
war and an act that divided them it is
the story we all know and yet there is
my third character and third silence the
Japanese boy who drifted back into my
consciousness after an absence of four
decades only a few years ago I no longer
remember how he and I were put in
context sometime in the mid-1950s like
me my Japanese pen pal must have been 11
or 12 years old if we exchanged photos I
have no memory of his face nor does a
name come to mind if I can remember half
jokingly writing my own address at that
age New York City New York USA planet
Earth solar system galaxy the universe I
can't remember writing his I already
knew by then that a place called Albany
was the capital of New York State but
New York City still seemed to me the
center of the world and in many ways I
wasn't wrong even if he lived in Tokyo
my Japanese pen pal could have had no
such illusions like me he had
undoubtedly been born during World War
two
perhaps in his first year of life he had
been evacuated from one of Japan's
charred cities for him that disastrous
war would not have been a memory if he
had gone to the movies with his father
in the 1950s he might have seen Godzilla
not the US Air Force dismantled Tokyo
and he might have hardly remembered
those economically difficult first years
of American occupation but he could not
at that time have imagined himself at
the center of the universe I have a
faint memory of the feel of his letters
a crinkly thinness undoubtedly meant to
save infinitesimal amounts of weight and
so money we wrote of course in English
from
of the planet if not the solar system
galaxy universe was beginning to operate
in that universal language that seemed
to radiate from my home city to the
world like the Rays of the Sun but what
I most remember are the exotic looking
stamps that arrived on or in his letters
for I was with my father an avid stamp
collector on Sunday afternoons my father
and I prepared and mounted our stamps
consulted our scotts catalog and pasted
them in in this way the Japanese section
of our album was filled with that boy's
offerings without comment but also
without protest from my father we
exchanged letters
none of which remain for a year or two
and then who knows what interest of mine
or his over Camus perhaps only the
resistance boys can have to writing
letters in any case he too entered a
realm of silence only now remembering
those quiet moments of closeness when my
father and I worked on our albums do I
note that he existed briefly and without
discussion in our lives he existed for
both of us perhaps in the ambiguous
space that silence can create and now I
wonder sometimes what kinds of nuclear
dreams my father may have had for all of
us the earth was knocked off its axis
on August 6 1945 in that one moment my
father's war ended and my war the Cold
War began but in my terms it seems so
much messier than that for we and that
boy continued to live in the same world
together for a long time accepting and
embroidering each other's silences when
I think of him now when I realized that
he my father and I still can't inhabit
the same story except in silence astray
a strange kind of emotion rushes up in
me which is hard to explain the bomb
still runs like a Fisher but also like
an attracting current a secret unity
through our lives the rented tour in
history was deep and the generational
divide given the experiences of those
growing up on either side of it profound
but any story would also have to hold
the ways even deeper and harder to
fathom in which we lived through it all
together in pain hatred love and most of
all silence
so now to change
that's just give us one moment to set up
the mic here yes okay well thank you
very much Tom I you know as tom was was
was reading his the second essay I had a
part because I both read it and I've
heard you read it before I started
drifting off into other war scenes that
we've all experienced collectively over
these years not just under the Bush
administration but also now the reality
that we're living in and and if you if
you think about it we remain a world on
fire you started off by talking about
the the fire of the nuclear bomb but we
we we truly are in a world on fire the
the uprisings throughout the Arab world
the OP rising in the United States the
Occupy movement here the situation in
Syria which deteriorates by the moment
the reality from Libya that the United
States still believes in regime change
by force you have an expanding air war
in Pakistan and Yemen in Somalia you
have night raids you have an expansion
of the use of special operations forces
and yet we remember the pledges that
President Obama made when he was
candidate Obama how he was going to
dismantle the Bush Doctrine and he was
going to re-engage the world and indeed
the first several executive orders that
he issued dealt with dismantling parts
key parts of the torture apparatus in
the United States pledges to close
Guantanamo the United States doesn't
torture bottom line in fact he gave that
speech at the at the National Archive
and yet if we fast forward to where we
are now and we look at it
how big of a break have we seen from the
Bush Doctrine when it comes to foreign
policy well I think it up until recently
there was relatively little break I mean
that is I would put it this way in the
Bush administration we already saw a
break from the Bush Doctrine that is the
you have the first Bush years and then
you have what I would call the gates
doctrine which was kind of a a
management doctrine for the disaster of
the Bush Doctrine referring to defense
secretary of defense secretary Robert
Gates and and of course when Obama came
in the first signal of what was going to
happen was he he kept gates and he took
as his national security adviser someone
who was a friend of John McCain so so in
a sense we knew I mean the one thing I
can proudly say is that that within two
weeks after Obama taken over I wrote a
piece called
don't let it barack obama break your
heart because i could already see at
least him what we used to call foreign
policy where he was going and and what
you had for those first few years was
you really had a continuation of the
latter period of the the latter Bush
years you know the ongoing two wars the
ratcheting up of the of counter-terror
and so on and so forth
I think we have gotten to a point
something is changing now that's what I
think I think it's almost a tectonic
moment partially because first of all
it's a word nobody likes in this country
generally but let's let's say it defeat
you know we were defeated in Iraq you
know the greatest army on earth was was
the greatest military I mean I mean this
was this was the bush people were
romantics about the American military
they thought it could do anything and it
turned out it could destroy a lot it
just couldn't build a damn thing and and
in the end it had to leave it left Iraq
and we've seen just the other day the
embassy staff is now being slashed maybe
by half we can see that Iraq is fading
and that the Iraq that's left well a
total mess is also closer to Iran than
it ever would have been under any other
circumstances so Iraq is is kind of a
goner in that sense Afghanistan you can
feel their urge to get those troops out
of Afghanistan not the Special Forces
people and so on and so forth by
Afghanistan is going to we had this week
this lieutenant colonel this
truth-teller Davis
Daniel Davis writing a piece and it got
a lot of attention he wrote a piece
saying everything that the military
people was saying in Iraq in Afghanistan
was a lie you know and and he said I've
been on the ground for a year and I have
seen nothing of success not a bit of it
okay so that was interesting that got a
lot of attention what didn't get
attention and I thought was truly
interesting was that his piece which is
which was like a whistleblower piece
appeared in Armed Forces Journal and
that tells me that there are a lot of
people in the military who know that
Afghanistan is an utter disaster too so
you've got two more disasters the answer
is we're now heading into a new period
and it's really your period journey
where we're we're heading what I call
offshore literally offshore I mean in
the sense that we're you know it's going
to be the Navy offshore in terms of the
Air Force and drones skies but also as I
wrote recently we're heading offshore of
national sovereignty we're trying to
create a new kind of American Way of war
I would say I mean it's been coming for
a long while and you've been reporting
on it but a new kind of American Way of
war in which from wherever we are we can
bust into any other country and only one
country on earth has sovereignty that's
us of course you know one of the one of
I think that the the key moments in the
in the history of the Obama
administration's foreign policy that has
gotten almost no media attention is when
when when General when David Petraeus
was the commander of CENTCOM US Central
Command which in the area of operations
for Central Command extends to the
entire Middle East and the Arabian
Peninsula and and for a period now it's
under AFRICOM but for a period it also
included East Africa so it was it was
Somalia and the US had a base in
Djibouti that they took over from the
French and reformed it into a into a CIA
and Special Operations Forces base that
was used to strike inside of Somalia but
when Petraeus was the CENTCOM commander
he issued he authorized something called
the a qnx sword the al Qaeda Network
execute order in September of 2009
and it was it was a a limited view paper
only order that was that authorized
commanders in the field to have far
greater latitude u.s. military
commanders field to conduct lethal
operations outside of the stated
battlefields of Iraq and Afghanistan and
what what it represented was an Obama
administration co-signing of an earlier
order that was issued under Bush at the
end of a 304 but that that piece of
paper was was a key moment in September
2009 when the Obama administration said
we we believe in the in the supreme
right of the United States to militarily
attack in any country and they were meet
anywhere in the world where we
determined there to be a terrorist
threat and it's it's it's the part of
the military justification and it's the
justification given to Congress also
when the military strikes in Yemen
because remember there were cruise
missile attacks in Yemen in December of
2009 just right after that order was
issued that you know killed tremendous
numbers of civilians they missed their
their so-called target those were
military operations they were not
briefed to the Intelligence Committee
it's a circumvention of any effective
oversight and and and you you move
toward where we are now President Obama
signed a lethal authorization a lethal
finding to conduct a targeted
assassination of a United States citizen
Anwar Awlaki in Yemen he also killed
another US citizen in authorizing that
bombing Samir Khan who was the editor of
inspire magazine the the
english-language publication put out by
al Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula and
then two weeks later a US drone strike
kills Abdul Rahman Allah key the
sixteen-year-old son of Anwar Awlaki
who also was a US citizen who had not
talked to his father in three years and
and and so I raised that because I spent
a lot of time battling on Twitter when
I'm on deadline for real stories
what's it and so that's my test pool and
I get I engage with old Baal engage with
someone who has three followers and
fight them for an entire afternoon and I
have 40 something thousand but so just
that's that's that's how deep into the
trenches I'll get in the mud but um but
but the point is what's incredible to me
is the number of seemingly
well-intentioned
liberals who are so willing to defend
the White House's right to assassinate a
US citizen who has not been indicted in
a US Court and is not shooting at US
soldiers and and I think if McCain had
been president people would have been up
in arms about this Glenn Greenwald would
not be a pariah among sort of Obama BOTS
people he would he would be a guy who
people are saying oh let's listen to
Glenn Greenwald because he's a
constitutional law expert now it's Glenn
Greenwald if people know he's the
salon.com
columnist and a wonderful mind it would
be he would be viewed as as you know a
this serious person that he is and as he
was taken by those same people under
Bush and now he's become a symbol of
well those people are irreconcilable
ingress to be President he's normalized
these policies for a huge number of
liberals in this country including
killing our own citizens with no trial
though there was a recent Washington
Post I'm sure you saw an ABC poll which
showed that that I mean among some
figures that were a lot better it showed
that 83% of Americans including like a
significant fifty odd percent of liberal
Democrats were in favor of drone strikes
wherever I mean it was it was actually a
higher figure than that it was 83
percent for for killing a lackey it was
maybe in the 50s but a 60 65 percent
actually so those those were striking
figures I mean I mean along with that
went 78 percent of Americans who if not
four were if not worked for withdrawal
from Afghanistan they were definitely
from four major drawdown so I mean this
is this I think to a lot of Americans
looks like the easier cleaner you know
less casualty field less expensive path
and I think in a way it looks that way
to the Obama administration to
conceptually what it's done and what
it's doing is to turn the globe into you
know in Vietnam there were certain areas
of Vietnam during the Vietnam War that
were called free-fire zones where you
could just in essence you could fire at
anything if you were an American soldier
up in an American plane whatever the the
Obama administration is now this is the
new thing that's happening I mean it's
been happening for
but they are turning the globe into a
free-fire zone for us and just to pick
up on Petraeus because he's an
interesting figure to follow beyond 2009
in fact I think he's fascinating today
David Petraeus he was portrayed in
Washington both sides of the aisle as
America's Savior in Iraq and then
Afghanistan he got out of both countries
just in time as far as I can see but he
he was dealt with he got more publicity
than any American general since what
MacArthur maybe you're Ike he then was
made you know partially probably a
political decision on Obama's part but
in terms of American politics but he was
made the CIA director and he has so you
have not a civilian but a military man
being made the CIA director and he went
himself into the shadows so you look now
there are no profiles of Petraeus
I mean he's hardly written about he goes
up and testifies every now and then but
it is remarkable how he's dropped out of
the news but at the same time what you
now have increasingly behind the scenes
in what in the 60s they used to call in
the shadows we see American war going
into the shadows and Petraeus is part of
that
he's a man who relied in Iraq and
Afghanistan on on special operations
forces hunter-killer teams night raids
and drones he's now running the CIA
which specializes in you know drones
hunter-killer teams and so on and so
forth and he's clearly coordinating with
the military so you you have those
worlds melding and and to add to that
one thing and this is an area you are
deeply into I know when we talk about
like with Osama bin Laden's killing when
we talk about the elite seal 16 we think
of it as some little group but the
special lock the special operations
forces are now part-time and full-time
60,000 it's a secret army like the CIA
developing within the military itself
and going into the shadows this is a
very ominous development and you have
different you have different tiers as
they call them of operators within the
Special Operations community you have
you have you know what are the sort of
the vanilla Special Operations guys the
SEAL Teams other than SEAL Team six and
then you have people that essentially
effectively operate as as a private army
at under the direct orders of the
president I mean he's the
commander-in-chief but he when the
Somali pirates for instance were taken
down in April 2009 and you know three
bullets three guys down that was you
know Obama on the phone with the SEAL
Team six commanders they're authorizing
that kill in progress and and but what's
happened is that you think in a world of
people that in the in the dirt of the
1980s when the US was engaged in all of
these wars in Central America the Contra
Wars that dirty war in Guatemala and
elsewhere these were the guys that
existed in the shadows and no one from
the rest of the military really wanted
much to do with them and they weren't
going to elevate within the US military
chain of command when General Stanley
McChrystal who was the commander of the
Joint Special Operations Command from
2003 to 2008 was appointed the commander
of US operations in Afghanistan
President Obama took someone who was
generally regarded as a shadow figure
like you're talking about and put him in
charge of an entire war and you saw a
dramatic expansion in the number of
night raids and the number of targeted
kill operations that were going on on
the ground in Afghanistan they have made
them the premier part of the u.s. war
machine rather than the sort of teams of
last resort or the guys we dare not
speak of they are now at the vanguard of
the of the whole thing and let's
remember at the beginning of the Bush
administration Bush Bush and Rumsfeld
and Cheney came in and and Rumsfeld and
Cheney in particular viewed the CIA as a
liberal institution that needed to be
put in a corner and and so they
dismantled the cooperation between the
CIA and the special operations forces
and they created a beast out of JSOC in
doing that out of the Joint Special
Operations Command Petraeus has brought
the whole thing full circle at the CIA
and so what bomber now has full spectrum
dominance going on with those forces
that Bush and Cheney spent several years
trying to divide and and and and that's
the reality that were
we're in right now III wanted to also
point something out time and ask you you
about this and it's it might be a little
outside of your Lane but I know you guys
have covered it on time dispatch the
discussion right now about Israel
possibly attacking Iran and the fact
that we're seeing all of these Iranian
scientists being assassinated with very
sophisticated explosive devices
motorcycles pull up they put them under
the car that scientist is then it is
then killed and and it's a it's a story
that hasn't gotten as much attention as
it should but it's it's happening at a
time when there's a lot of discussion
about whether or not Israel will attack
Iran yeah I mean I you know I did a
piece recited piece recently in which I
just simply took what we have done or
Israel has done in Iran and reversed it
and simply said we'll just imagine for a
minute imagine the aircraft carrier I
mean of course the Iranians don't have
an aircraft carrier it's impossible to
really do these reversals because they
we are still on a one-way planet but
imagine the the aircraft carrier the
home any you know off the Florida coast
and the drones flying over the United
States and some kinds of kill teams in
the capital you know or or in Los Alamos
slaughtering assassinating US scientists
and you know compute you know and and
and and and and viruses being sent into
our our nuclear system by you know worms
being sent into our our nuclear computer
system and so on and so if you start to
imagine this of course for us
there was one recent story in which it
was claimed that a Texas car salesman
had gone to the Mexican cartels and with
money from an Iranian an official
Iranian group had had had called for the
head WA had worked toward the
assassination to towards some
assassinations in Washington this may or
may not be a an accurate or real story
but if it is accurate we don't have that
much bigger if Iran's best agents
exactly but but this went when this hit
here you know we sent the Saudis to the
UN there was a resolution we went crazy
I mean it was it was headlines we said
it was beyond all human bounds but this
stuff in Iran nobody says anything of
course yes I mean I mean I mean the the
the program against Iran is startling on
the other hand I have never felt I I
mean the left has been talking about an
attack on Iran since 2003 Iran one of
those pieces of time dispatch and I
think 2003 or 2004 I you know even Dick
Cheney couldn't pull the trigger the
Obama administration doesn't want to
pull the trigger on Iran the the US
military doesn't and I think that no for
everything that the Israelis say that
for them to go into a war without a
green light from the United States it
could make them the least popular
country on earth here and it would be a
very dangerous thing for them to do so I
think there are there are restraints on
I mean this is a very dangerous
situation and the real danger I think is
not that somebody's going to immediately
decide to go into a war but that there
will be a miscalculation on one side or
another the people in Iran that in Iran
is very factionalized it's a weak
regional power but the people in Iran
running Iran right now are the hardline
part of that fundamentalist regime
partially thanks to policies that we've
carried out over the years I mean if you
go back I mean if you were in Washington
today and you were a reasonable person
and thinking about this you wouldn't
touch Iran everything we've done has
blown back 1953 we overthrew the
government installed the Shah that led
to home a knee nineteen late 1960s we
sold the first nuclear reactor to Iran
to create the problem we're now dealing
with we backed Saddam Hussein and his
invasion of I and cetera you can run
through all of this every single thing
the United States did was a catastrophe
I mean it's crazy that we're doing this
and the blowback from this I mean you're
a blowback guy the blowback from this
here on the US on the US economy
if if something goes wrong the blowback
on the US economy on all of us on the
gas prime units
be staggering this is like unbelievably
stupid I I find it amazing you know
something I want to add that I that I
see in the as I mentioned earlier I was
I was just in Yemen and one of the
things that sort of stunned me when I
was in Yemen was the degree to which
people spoke positively about al Qaeda
in the Arabian Peninsula and and but but
simultaneously dismissed them as
anything that the United States like
sort of perplexed as to why the United
States would take the threat so
seriously and and and you know numerous
try important tribal leaders said to me
don't you realize that when you guys
bomb here and you hit a village full of
people that you're pushing people to
support their agenda it's not and I'm
gonna have a piece in the nation about
this on my trip it's it's not that
people want to bring down American
aircraft over Detroit or that they want
to send Parcel bombs to Jewish community
centers in Chicago it's that the United
States has supported a dictatorship in
Yemen of Ali Abdullah Saleh
they gave him weapons they gave him
military aid they built up units that
were supposed to be for counterterrorism
that were then turned against the Yemeni
people and used against them when they
rose up and even when they weren't
rising up and and the the the government
there ceased to provide services and you
have people that are in some way or
another affiliated with al Qaeda that
for years have been saying the United
States is going to treat Yemen as their
next era Iraq Afghanistan Pakistan Anwar
Awlaki said the same thing that the
United States wants to turn Yemen into
its next Afghanistan and what do we do
well we start bombing Yemen and and and
and in the eyes of a lot of people
they're saying you've backed a dictator
we don't even have trash collection in
our community there's no such thing as a
court of law in much of of Yemen poverty
is biting and the regime's family
members are all bankrolled by the United
States so I'm gonna go with the people
that say Sharia law is is the only way
to bring law and order to our community
and what what I saw there and in Somalia
was not was people people flocking 12
but people's own indigenous belief
system starting to merge closer and
closer to that of the al-qaeda political
message and so the United States is
creating it's creating the very reality
that didn't exist but they claim to be
but it claimed to be fighting and making
it they're making it real and you have
to extend that to the world I mean that
is that is it was the one thing I was
going to say off you know I mean when
you start to talk about what we're doing
militarily it can sound awesome I think
the new version of our military first
policy the offshore version is going to
turn out to be another disaster and I
think it's worth just remembering to
dilute for a little potted history to go
back to the demonstrations you talked
about at the beginning for a little
potted history of our world in the 1990s
we sent out you could call them our
economic jihadis you know to kind of
flatten the world I mean they helped to
create the 1% of the 90 I mean there
were many disparities in the world but
they helped to increase those
disparities one percent ninety nine
percent in in the next decade the Bush
decade you could call it we sent out our
military first people who blew a hole
directly through the middle of the
Middle East the greater Middle East you
know they you know these these two sets
of Acts created the stage for I mean
they created it wasn't that they what
they globalized was protest they created
a planet on which everybody had in a way
whether it was Yemen or Egypt or Chile
or wherever
everybody had a 1% of the 99 percent and
a worse one than they had had 20 years
before you know so that we are now on a
planet we are now on a planet in which
it's true if you're in Tahrir Square and
you're in Moscow and you're in in Occupy
Washington or wherever you you have
different seeming issues but you are its
you've happened for the same reason and
the Obama doctrine whatever it turns out
to be will only increase this I think
you know it will only it will do what
you're talking about in Yemen it will do
in Pakistan it will do and wherever it
turns this is what it's going to do and
partially because you know Tom
dispatcher I'm proud to say you
the only site only place I think on this
planet that has counted up the number of
wedding parties I mean here we are we
talk about fear we are this country is
obsessed with a fear of terrorism there
was a study in The Times yesterday
14,000 murders in the United States last
year number of murders from Islamic
extremists zero but Tom dispatch has
counted up through about 2009 the number
of wedding parties blown away by the US
Air Force seven of them it's absolutely
startling I mean when you when you're
blowing away wedding parties those are
just ones only not that those are just
once we know an envelope all is here you
know one of the the great reporters who
really has done much to to expose what's
happened in Afghanistan and I'm sure
because I've talked about it with him
that he would attest this too but we
probably know a tiny fraction of the the
killing that has happened and you know
and that's just talking about the u.s.
killing that's happened or civilian
deaths that have been caused by night
raids based on bad intelligence so you
may have been able to compile the ones
that we know we know about reported
absolutely and we know it's more we
probably should open this up to
questions from I just want to say what
one other thing briefly I remember I I
spent a lot of time in Iraq starting in
I guess it was late late 1997 I first
went to Iraq and and was there
consistently from from then through the
beginning of the of the so-called shock
and awe and I remember that with the day
that that Saddam statue was pulled down
by Ahmed Chalabi --zz people and the
United States military but that it was
sort of portrayed as it was Iraqis going
and taking down the statue of Saddam and
Pharaohs square I remember I got all
these emails from people saying you know
look you were wrong about everything and
and look at all the Iraqis are
celebrating and they're you know it's
exactly what you know what Wolfowitz and
others said was gonna happen and sort of
sticking it in my face and you know I
would invite them to take a look at Iraq
today and and you know the horrifying
reality that exists for so many Iraqis
they have their people people are
probably begging for Saddam to be back
which says a lack of Saddam you I was
told stories by people whose children
said that their dad was smarter than
Saddam Hussein
and someone comes to the home and then
cuts the father's tongue out I mean this
this was real stuff under Saddam when I
was there when Abu Ghraib prison was
emptied in October of 2002 and Saddam
let 30,000 prisoners out and some people
came out chanting down down Qasim
because the who ruled Iraq before Saddam
and the bath party took over a half a
century earlier they had been in prison
for so long they didn't know who was the
president of Iraq so there's no no doubt
about it it was brutal so for people to
say it was better under Saddam is really
saying something
but I raised that because the the Libya
the u.s. Libya bombing and of course
it's an extreme we could spend four
hours analyzing what happened in Libya
they're there there's the convergence of
popular uprisings and then the the the
might of empire military which is the
you know NATO coming in and I think that
however you view the internal dynamics
in Libya what overthrew Muammar Qaddafi
was the what was the bombing campaign
far more than any domestic insurrection
within Libya the two converged but
without that airpower Qaddafi probably
would not have fallen as swiftly as he
did Syria there's a lot of people
pushing for for the United States or for
NATO to go in and and bomb Syrian
friends of mine that two years ago were
pro-assad are saying no we want the
United States to come in and bomb and
they point to videos that they see from
from Homs and elsewhere but who's asking
the question what comes after what's
what's been dismantled is an Arab
nationalism that really kept in check
some of the forces that we're seeing
rise up some of the Islamist forces the
Salafist movements in other countries
people have been so thoroughly punished
by some of these us-backed dictatorship
they turn deeper and deeper toward
religion and I I don't get a sense I
know and I don't know I'd be curious on
what you think Tom that US policymakers
are thinking much further than the news
cycle and and and and what public
pressure seems to be brought on large
media outlets or by influential
permanent think tankers I mean so much
so much of what we think of as policy
overseas is actually driven by what's
going on here I mean just to give you an
autograph
I mean we have an odd political
situation here where normally a Democrat
would rule on the issue of jobs and the
Republicans would rule on the issue of
national security now now this this is
kind of reversed at this point
Obama rules on national security I mean
the the polls show that people back his
national security policy
he killed Osama bin Laden etc etc so the
Republicans are forced into the strange
and almost mad position of demanding the
one thing they can demand is that he
attack Iran tomorrow in essence a my
answer by the way on war on Iran is is
if is is if you know one of the
Republicans get in we we really are
probably in trouble on that but but so
so so he so there were presented to him
said that the Crusades got a bad rap
yeah I did see that and but but but in
the same way that's totally true but in
the same in the same way Obama is for I
mean by what the Republicans are doing
on Iran Obama is forced to take a
stronger and stronger policy on our he
himself is being pushed on Iran to take
an ever stronger policy and this is this
is domestic policy domestic politics
playing into what's and I think that
these guys on the whole that I mean
first of all the thing I would say about
the Obama administration generally is
but the bush people were visionaries
they were mad visionaries but they had a
vision of the globe of how it worked and
how it should work they were completely
wrong they were crazy visionaries the
Obama people are kind of managers and I
think they're managing just as you say
by the moment by the week you know not
by the year they they I don't think they
have any vision of what's happening
they're just they're almost just trying
to keep up with events now that time and
I have thoroughly uplifted everyone and
that's right
we'll open it up and if we can try to
have some gender equity in the
questioning that would be that would be
great so do you have this gentleman here
yeah yeah she's bring it to you
I I'd like to ask your if you've heard
about it and believe that sufficient
attention has been paid in terms of the
press to the following in September of
last year Christopher Edley the Dean of
the California law school who was also
on the transition the Obama transition
team I understand he was number six the
he was at a conference where they were
discussing law and order and what came
up was John Lewis in the universe you
know has tenure again in in the same
University and what came up was a
question about shall the Obama
administration prosecute those people
who've committed crimes in the previous
administration and he said he voted
along with it sounded like six or seven
other people to recommend that they
don't prosecute the offenders in the
previous administration and he he said
it was I guess it was unanimous and he
gave his reason and this is the
important thing I would think he gave us
his reason that if they did he felt that
the CIA and the military would would
manage a cool later I understand when he
was questioned further on and he
responded with an email and so forth and
because the president was asking me said
mentioned something about justice and he
says sometimes justice has to give way
to politics that was his statement later
we try to defend that have you heard
about it and because as far as I might
know it hasn't made much maspeedy repute
I haven't heard about that but but but I
first of all I would say that I I find
it a little hard to believe I I actually
don't think a coup III the military
would have no reason in the United
States to launch a coup they've got more
or less what they want I mean that's
that's I but but but but I I would say
that that that the Obama administration
gonna look forward not backward and he
has you know and I think actually the
striking thing about this moment and I
don't think it's just a matter of the
CIA in the military
is that the that the whole national what
I would call the national security
complex has simply passed out of our
legal system totally that is in you know
we are still in our legal system but if
you are in the national security complex
whatever you do you will never be
accountable for it and no one has been
accountable for anything I don't think
it matters whether it's torture or
anything else there's only one crime as
far as I can see in in post legal
America in terms of the national
security state and that crime is
whistleblowing and the Obama
administration has time and time again
and Glen rein Greenwald's been great on
this and Tom dispatch has covered as
well going after anybody who would tell
Americans what's going on inside the
government that's what I would say and I
think another important part of this is
the United States if you go and you look
at various speeches by Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton has been
consistently calling for or supporting
processes of accountability in other
countries in Kenya and elsewhere around
the world and saying there has to be an
accounting for these and the the logic
of it is is brilliant in that they're
saying the only way to prevent this from
happening again is to expose what
happened and then hold those responsible
accountable but that's for the rest of
the world for us it's it's you know we
need to move forward and I mean I'm
gonna try that if I get pulled over for
speeding there's a forward officer not
backward but but it but I think the most
the most serious ramification of that
that policy which I really questioned
seriously the wisdom of it is that you
have you have there's no incentive to to
think twice about doing those things if
you're in the field and you feel you can
justify it and you know I think there
are a lot of intelligence professionals
in the United States that were
absolutely repulsed by what their
colleagues did and there and I know of
people within the CIA who quietly
resigned and there was never a story
done about them the those people I do
believe represent the vast majority of
people that work in the US intelligence
apparatus I
not believe that they support torture
and and I think there would be a lot of
support for some process of
accountability they might not want the
accountability many people in this room
may see as sufficient but I agree with
Tom that there you know there's there's
no need for any kind of a coup d'etat
you know that's that President Obama has
been so generous to the Special
Operations community not not just on the
level of supporting them militarily but
also in supporting the agenda of some of
the more aggressive commanders Admiral
William McRaven who's been promoted to
the head of Special Operations Command
well McChrystal got taken down in a
different way but he and Obama were very
close on a military level Petraeus
ascending to the ranks of CIA they're
the military-industrial complex and
those within the military that are the
the real power brokers are faring quite
well under President Obama
accountability or not yeah
hi um thank you for speaking by the way
I really appreciate that
I especially appreciate ya I especially
appreciate discussion about the Japanese
and what it actually reminded me of was
Korematsu V United States which is still
the prevailing law it's the law is that
um you can discriminate by race only if
it's for the purposes of preserving
national security and I was wondering
with the passage of the National Defense
Authorization Act what that holds for
the future not only of American
minorities but also of people abroad but
also of just people abroad because I
know that we were talking about how
there's a mirror yeah yeah do you okay
um I I think I think I would almost just
repeat what I've already said which is
simply that I mean the thing that's
striking in our moment is that that
whatever the government decides it's
going to do and and we've seen this now
over a decade it then calls together a
group of lawyers and the lawyers create
a legal explanation for it
a legal justification for it often at
length I mean like we know although we
haven't seen it that they are the Oh
Lackey assassination that there's a
50-page legal justification by the
Justice Department's lawyers it hasn't
been released but we know it's there I
don't think it's been released anyway uh
and and and once they've created this
justification it's called legality and
then they do it so I mean at this point
the the the national security state I
mean think of it as like a mothership
that's lifted off the American earth and
it is creating its own reality you know
and it's creating it on one basis and
that basis is terrorism I mean this is
why I called my book the United States
of fear because it is it is it is the
infusion of fear and into the society
that's created the national security
state as we know it the state that state
is incredible the Cold War state was
huge there was at least in the Cold War
some a country we called an enemy and it
had a huge nuclear arsenal that had an
enormous military it it it would now we
have a
the world a couple of minority
insurgencies a few thousand jihadi
people who want to do something to the
United States maybe we have a couple of
weak regional powers who we declare
enemies I mean it's a really a poultry
thing and the national security state
based on fear is so much bigger than
anything in the Cold War period
it's absolutely staggering and I think
the one thing you could say okay you
wanted to go well no I was I I mean just
adding it more and directly trying to
address part of what you you said there
when I flew in to JFK from Yemen a
couple weeks ago I had a nice little
chat with the guy at customs
he then swipes my pack he said I said I
was in Yemen he said what are you doing
it told him you know I'm a journalist
bah blah he said God well welcome home
glad you're safe swipes my passport and
goes whoa and and and and you know I
ended up in this place in JFK called
area three and and had a
counterterrorism review interview where
they're asking me if I about do I have
military experience explosives training
to have weapons training and we had this
sort of back and forth and they asked me
about some previous trips that popped up
on their machine and and I this has
happened to me a number of times where
I'll get you know when you go to Somalia
you probably can expect that they're
gonna pull you in for for some
questioning but but the reason I bring
it up is because in that in those rooms
every time I've been taken I am always
the only white person always and I'm
always the first one to leave you know
and and I've seen people get taken into
another room
I've seen people sitting there and
sitting there and sitting there and it's
every time I leave I feel I feel like
I've participated in something
horrifying because in this particular
case and I was on Egypt air I I was
sitting in Cairo across before I flew
back to United States from this couple
that had two little kids and I was
watching them play and I was zoning
outside just been in you know within
this al-qaeda controlled area in in
Yemen and I was just I was enjoying
zoning out and watching these two kids
play with their parents and that family
was in that room and they came there and
and and they were there before I got
there and they
they're what I when I was leaving if you
if you look at it I mean we we are a
nation that is racially and religiously
and ethnically profiling people
regardless of who's in power the the
hearings that that Representative Peter
King has held about radicalization it's
all meant to terrorize the American
people it's meant to make us afraid and
and the statistics that Tom cited I
think are very important for all
Americans to hear about who is killing
people inside of this country on a
regular basis what kinds of incidents
actually threaten our national security
and that the sacred cow that no one
wants to touch in this arena is what
kind of foreign policy would actually
make us safer because you know what a
war of attrition isn't going to do it
there's not a finite number of bad guys
that you kill and it's over our policy
is creating terrorism and and and I
think that is that is the hardest debate
that people in this country have to have
is is first to own that and and then say
what do we do about it now you know you
know the the Bush administration
discovered very quickly that that fear
of a very specific sort was a kind of a
gold mine I mean I have to say you know
normally when you get ruling groups the
striking thing about ruling groups is
before they manipulate anybody else they
tend to manipulate themselves so that so
that I mean if you look back at our Lee
Cold War documents from the National
Security Council people writing to 30 40
50 other people you know where nobody
else was going to see it the language is
the kind of anti-communist language you
would expect them to be using to
manipulate people out there but first
they're convincing each other so I'm
sure the bush people were in their own
way scared but but they found very
quickly that fear it wasn't just fear it
was fear of a very specific sort and
that was purely fear of terrorism now it
is a weird thing since 9/11 I've taken a
look at this and I think you can count
somewhere between 25 and 30 deaths in
the United States due to anything you
might vaguely call terrorism and that
includes the Gabriel Giffords killings
and the the guy wasn't killed but other
know the other people who were killed
there and the guy the the the the guy
the angry guy who plunged his plane into
an IRS building and I think Austin and
killed himself and an IRS guy I mean
this is worse than shark attacks and not
worse than any other danger Americans
face but this is what I mean you name it
33,000 people dead on the roads 14,000
murders
dust devils kill more I mean I mean it's
unbelievable
and and of course then there are the
real dangerous of our world I mean I
mean lost jaw I mean if you were to
simply count up the number of people I
know this without doing it the number of
people who have killed somebody because
they lost a job or lost their home or
killed themselves in the process you
would be in staggering figures by
comparison so so but the this little
thing the government has given us a 100%
guarantee on only one thing things that
we really need it on we don't get it but
on this you know we we are we are
supposed to and that's why airports and
everywhere else
we've gone crazy and they've built they
built a structure filled with money you
know that that guarantee is a small
number of people lifetime jobs and
everything else they're never gonna go
under III think it's a terrible striking
thing that I will say I was quite I was
quite pleased though in Yemen every time
I got in a plane there I was always the
person searched the most thoroughly of
anyone I whatever profile it is that
they're looking for which is pricey I am
do we have any other questions here yeah
oh this is better it's bill Hartung is
it yet from oh my god I think we have to
speak up bill for tonight yeah Jeremy
you talked about sort of jokingly how
uplifting the conversation is which in a
way I think it is too speaking truth to
power is uplifting but you know Tom
you've talked about American culture the
addiction to violence how do we get
traction in the country where even
liberals are saying target assassination
makes sense drone wars makes sense
essentially as long as we don't get hurt
in Americans it doesn't seem information
doesn't seem to be enough so what where
do we get our footing we're going
attraction not only to inform people but
to inspire them to push for progressive
foreign policy I'm asking you this
partly because people always ask me this
therefore I want your answer so I can
use which I don't have you I mean I I I
think that that you know part of part of
the problem of the last several years is
that I think we were at a moment where
most Americans regardless of their
political views were were sick of these
wars what regardless of whether they
supported them initially or they or
their views on how you fight terrorism
and all those things I think people were
getting sick of wars and I do think that
the economic crisis in the country
created a moment where those people that
had been agitating against these wars
could also make an economic argument
that wouldn't necessarily have been
there their predominant argument that
they would have made in opposing the
wars but it would have resonance with a
lot more people who as people were
losing their jobs and and an endless
money was still being spent on on these
wars I I do I do think that the the fact
that you have a very popular president
among liberals President Obama who has a
social agenda that while some on the
left side of the Democratic Party and
certainly people to the left of the
Democratic Party are very disillusioned
with he remains extremely popular among
the the the huge base of
middle-of-the-road or mainstream
Democrats and the fact that he is also
perceived to be infinitely smarter than
Bush and I think it's a correct
perception has it has really pulled the
rug out from under people arguing
against these wars because in in terms
of the debate in the public sphere and I
think it's why you see the poll numbers
like we saw support for drone strikes
support for the killing of all Lackey
because I think people tend to think
he's smart he's a constitutional law
expert he must know what he's doing and
and and and I will say the Obama
administration they're very
sophisticated in trying to figure out
legalistic ways to continue some of
Bush's policies and to make them lawful
that that is if there was a very
that's a very damaging aspect of this
presidency for those in the anti-war
camp who want the u.s. out of all these
places and to stop with the targeted
assassinations I do think if a
Republican had been president it would
have been a very different discussion
having said that I think I think we have
to persevere it in a way it was I
remember I remember I'm old enough now
and have gray and my beard so I I was I
lived during the Clinton era as an adult
and I mean I wouldn't necessarily act
like an adult but I was an adult or and
I remember it was a dark dark period
when you were trying to mobilize against
you know us bombings the bombing of
Sudan the the bombing of Afghanistan the
78th day bombing of Yugoslavia over
Kosovo with no UN authorization it was a
big NATO adventure there are periods
like that when the the tentacles of
empire extended by Democrats and
normalized for a lot of the population I
think we're in one of those periods
right now I I think it's a real uphill
battle and I think it's in large part
because Obama has effectively convinced
a large portion of his base that this is
the right way to go and you can say well
I'm drawing down in Iraq and Afghanistan
so people have the perception it's it's
it's sort of coming to an end but in
reality it's just it's a shift in
tactics so I wanted to say something to
be as helpful as I could be that's Bill
Hartung who by the way has done a
wonderful book about locking Lockheed
macchina and has been has been toiling
in the fields of of turning out good
information for a long time and I want
to say I I think we have to take longer
view and I as I sat here and listened to
you
I was remembering some you know a month
back or whenever it was I was at I was
standing at the edge of Zuccotti Park
when a whole bunch of Union people it
was a March and they came they simply
appeared and I was surrounded by these
guys and there was there was a big guy
next to me I forget which Union he was
from and he was looking down on what
looked a little like a hippie encampment
on from the 60s and I my my experience
of the 60s was this should have been a
moment of hostility and he started off
he said you know he said these the this
99% we were talking about the one
sended the 99% for years I thought I I
thought he was I was gonna think oh my
god you know he's now he's going to
attack them you know they've taken
they've gotten the credit he said it's
so great they've put this on the map you
know and I thought this is wonderful you
know and and but I thought to myself as
well you know it was true that that that
parts of the labor movement had been
working on had been talking about the
99% it just hadn't gotten traction yet
drones it hasn't gotten traction yet and
I kind of know why I mean being like it
being against a drone given how they've
been presented generally in the United
States it's like being against an iPhone
or something you know I mean a sexy
perfect weapon you know I mean they're
not there they will be disasters I mean
or like or put it another way
like all perfect weapons they from the
tank on they never deliver what they
what the the the fabulous things they're
supposed to deliver but they settle they
embed themselves into our world and
become you know in the case of drones
will become almost everything in our
world I'm afraid but but I think there
is hope I think if we just keep at it we
are we're not on that old planet anymore
we now are on a planet of protest here
and elsewhere and we don't know where
that's going to go and we don't know
when people are going to make the
connection between domestic issues and
the foreign issues it hasn't fully been
made yet but but it will be I think it's
just my thought hi I was interested in
the criticism that you both seem to have
of the media and of journalists and you
kind of alluded to this news cycle
mentality where the cycle is just kind
of feeding on itself rather than at
minimum reflecting reality or kind of
attempting a sustained analysis of
what's going on to the degree to which
policy is becoming more reactionary to a
news cycle rather than maybe a different
time where the news cycle would actually
respond to the policy so I wanted to
know what you thought the origins of
kind of this media monster might be and
then what your advice is for journalists
now to do the kind of work that needs to
be done
it's a good question you know I um I I
think that it it's it long predates you
know my birth the role that the media
that powerful media outlets have played
in in in fueling conflict and war and it
also has to do with with media ownership
and at a different time in history in
fact what Juan Gonzales who's a great
columnist for The New York Daily News
and is a couple days a week the co-host
on Democracy Now wrote a brilliant book
that's a that is really a it's a history
of media owned owned by a small group of
corporations going back a couple hundred
years in the United States to the first
creations of newspapers within the
United States and and and in telling the
story he describes how a relatively
small group of people have always sort
of been in control of news dissemination
and that they're part of the same
circles of people that are in charge of
deciding US policy but it's it's also
documented in a very fascinating way and
the way that he tells the story is great
so I recommend people to look for awhile
Gonzalez's book on this I think though
that the the cable news the creation of
24-hour cable news was we crossed some
sort of a line there into a different
reality when you know you could you
could turn on the TV and at any moment
see some pundit or talking head pushing
their agenda and you know that the think
tanks are on there endlessly no offense
bill the the army of former generals
embedded in the newsrooms of CNN and
MSNBC and Fox News who also were getting
briefings from the Pentagon on what they
should be saying when they go on these
TV networks I mean there is a sort of
attempt to manufacture consent that that
is a concerted effort but I also think
that we've had a real sensationalization
of news and and you know if it bleeds it
leads and and and you have the sort of
rise of aggregator sites that are more
curated you know when Daily Beast's
started although they've started to do
more of their own reporting huffington
post you know has really good reporters
on Capitol Hill and White House you know
Sam Stein and Ryan Grimm are both really
great reporter
in Ryan grim is a friend of mine and he
does great reporting but it's also you
know it's it's it's an operation of sex
sells pop culture cells and it's that's
flashing at you on the on the screen and
I think that in a way we've we have a
media culture now that wants to see
those celebrity moments represented in
every aspect that the the the obsession
with celebrity culture and you know lulz
cats and all that stuff is now our
coverage of Libya and Syria and it has
to be it has to be it has to be sexy it
has to be graphic it has to be now now
now something has to be done about it
and I think that that's part of our
short attention span society if you look
at the Obama administration's very slow
response to the uprising in Egypt and
sort of the flirtation with keeping
Mubarak on I I don't think had it not
been for Al Jazeera I don't believe that
the Obama administration would have
taken the position it finally did on
Mubarak when it did I think it would
have taken a lot longer and maybe that
was a case where a media outlet did
something that had an end result that
was good
Wolf Blitzer has been really pushing for
war against Syria I mean almost overtly
you can you see he almost wants to make
love to the war on Syria it's like so
into it and it's like wolf men take a
xanax or something you know I think it's
I I do think it's I think it's cable
news and I think it's the sort of you
know tabloid ization of news culture in
this country combined with an industry
of think tankers and pundits largely
drawn from their former government
positions and still advocating for
whatever their friends within the
structure wants to see happen I don't
know yeah there were a lot out there
yeah I'll just say two too little I mean
just these are almost examples but I I'm
still struck that that that when you in
all the period when you read about Iraq
I mean I mean every couple of years
there was an anniversary of something
the invasion or whatever you know that
was celebrated or or or or whatever it
was and always they the experts they
asked
were the experts who had made a mistake
on Iraq or wanted to invade Iraq I mean
I mean to this day I have just about
never seen in the mainstream somebody
who was out in the streets and you could
find journalists who were out in the
streets who went out to protest the
invasion of Iraq you know you cannot you
it's the people who you know they're I
think it was George ball back in the in
the Kennedy Johnson days who said about
being inside an administration he said
you can be a hawk and be wrong and and
you're kept the only thing you can't be
is be a dove and be right you know and
and there's something about that in the
media too and and in particularly in the
world of punditry and it's very striking
the other names who's chosen to be on
these shows you know I mean if you it's
the same that are you you don't have
actual dissidents in the United States
that are saying you know we don't we
never call people that but there are
dissidents in the United States who are
very very sharp people and they're
almost never allowed on those shows and
have to have former something in front
of you to be look at the Republican
debate sponsored by the American
Enterprise Institute where David
Addington you know Cheney's former head
trainer and and Paul Wolfowitz are
allowed to ask questions as though they
have any business being out in public
without someone coming up and
confronting them for what they did about
Iraq and yet here they are right asking
a question as though they're just
ordinary Americans with concerns about
foreign policy you know you you don't
deserve to be dude there and yet that's
who CNN has in their debate asking
questions you know the other thing I was
struck by the other day there's a
there's a journalism website that that
that weekly offers a kind of a rundown
of what they call you know at least a
journalistic term they called the news
hole you know what was in the news hole
this week and I looked for January at
the news hole and it was really striking
the the the media news hole was 41%
campaign 2012 that was the the overall
media news hole which included you know
papers TV probably the internet so the
the online stuff and so on and so forth
and and and when you say 41% very little
of that's Obama it's almost all the the
on the ongoing Republican debate story
and cable news it was sixty four percent
that was the news hole that's what was
there you know and and and to me one of
the most striking things about that is
you know whatever people write about it
they don't write the one thing that
seems to me most obvious which is the
one thing that comes from this coverage
if you make this election the election
of the century the the money that comes
in to particularly cable news station
owners I mean it's the ads all those
attack ads if it's up there and it's big
and three people are vying you get
twenty million dollars in Florida or
forty million dollars in Florida and
that all comes in mostly to TV stations
this is one of the great conflict of
interests of our time and if it happened
in some other business somebody would
notice but nobody says a word about it
it's just unwritten well I mean let's be
honest I've met they show Mad Men was
not on during these Republican debates
so people needed something to watch and
maybe we should call it quits because we
people have been selling for a long
while you have you're not allowed to
leave oh I can't leave yet you have you
have you have four more minutes okay so
then I'm gonna interrupt the question
thank you both for being here I was
wondering if you could address how
perhaps one can actually view you know
Warren
Iran has an a sense already started by
the Obama administration and I'm not
talking about military strikes but I'm
talking about sanctions and sanctions on
Iran have been going on for a while now
but what the Obama administration did in
December right before New Year's Eve
those sanctions are extremely I think
frightening and can be considered a war
now we're reading reports about grain
shipments being turned away from Iran
because there's a freeze on financial
transactions from my understanding at
the central bank
aren't entirely complete but if I'm
speaking to my father in Iran I see that
he's talking about business is
absolutely halting and these grain
shipments being turned around so to
think about a little bit if you could
comment on sanctions not only paving the
path to war as we saw happen in Iraq but
you had Bush father then you had the
Clinton administration who imposed the
hardest sanctions in modern history and
then continued by Bush after him and
then there was war but how again so we
see in Iran I think the sanctioning of
the central bank is arguably a war an
economic war on the Iranian people but
also you know to take seriously that
it's not just you know because people
defend Obama saying well you know he's
doing this to not do that but how they
also are preparation for war I don't
sorry and I don't mean to but you know
so this is this one this is one thing
and secondarily I was you know really
pleased and not surprised given who the
two of you are to see you here you know
speak with such a opposition to what was
done to Iraq the US invasion of Iraq and
simultaneously talk about the
egregiousness I mean that's even too
light of a word of the Saddam Hussein
government and I bring this up now
because people are organizing against a
war and Iran slowly it's a trickle but
it's happening but one thing that causes
me great distress I was just at an anti
Iran war sanctions protest on Saturday
is that a section of the left maybe
they're small but they're you know
significant and I think really a scourge
on an anti-war movement are attacking
sorry you finished Jeremie iranian hsihu
are simultaneously taking people who are
taking a position against war on
sanctions but also the repression of
Iranian government's if you can speak to
that but let me just say not that that
this is not something that's only being
said and I just want to point out since
we were talking about the Republican
debates that one striking bit of
cognitive dissonance there dissonance
rather than dissidents is is that you
have one guy in the Republican debates
standing there saying things that should
send a Republican to hell and that's Ron
Paul who has been saying very directly
that sanctions are an act of war that
these sanctions are an act of war I mean
it is strange you will not find this
among Democrats right now but you will
find he's the one person eyes
see who up there in any major way who is
saying that and obviously I mean they're
not only they're not only potentially
acts of war but they strike against
they're not going to strike against the
Iranian leadership they're going to
strike against ordinary Iranians which
is of course what happened in Iraq as
well in the Saddam Hussein years and and
and and of course there are all sorts of
dangers in our world as well
because I mean I I mean the thing that
that's only a bit talked about in our
world is if something really blows with
Iran and that oil flow ceases you know
it's gonna you know it's gonna be worse
than the Libyan situation and our the
the global economy is going to suffer I
mean this is one of these as well this
is one of these mad situations in which
you could end up with a great recession
a great depression I mean the blowback
from this could be enormous and and and
so I think it's a dangerous situation I
think it's something that should be
organized against you know I don't know
don't the only thing I'll say in closing
about about that is you know the there
are different kinds of sanctions and and
you know if you there are sanctions that
are aimed at cutting off a regimes
weapons supply which is particularly
ironic when when the United States is
simultaneously profiting from a regimes
oil and then saying they're sanctioning
them on a different level I mean it's it
gives you a pretty clear sense if you
actually get into the mechanics of
sanctions the hypocrisy of the u.s. is
all over the mechanics of sanctions it
was in Iraq as well encouraged in oil
smuggling that the u.s. was the primary
beneficiary of when when the sanctions
were imposed on Iraq and the primary
people that were punished by the Iraq
sanctions were of course the Iraqi
people not the the regime and I and so
you know sanctions can be a form of
economic warfare and and and not all
sanctions are created equal and I think
that you know people are kind of giving
the administration a pass by just saying
oh it's sanctions sound like an
alternative to war they're not always an
alternative to war they certainly
weren't in the case of Iraq in a way
they I think more people died as a
result of the sanctions on Iraq than
died during the
the entire US military campaign in Iraq
which is which is stunning if you think
about it and I saw it firsthand in the
in the 1990s so and and I think a lot of
people are around the world right to be
concerned with what's going to happen
throughout the Arabian Peninsula what's
going to happen in the Middle East and
North Africa what's going to happen out
of Afghanistan we're in a world on fire
right now and some some of those fires
it's good that they're burning and I
don't necessarily mean violent fires I
mean fires of resistance to in the
United States and elsewhere and some of
them could really rage to a point where
it grows beyond you know control and and
there's one other thing to say about
sanctions which is not clear 30 seconds
30 seconds which is not clear here which
is here it looks as though sanctions is
some kind of global policy that
everybody agrees on in fact the United
States agrees on it Israel agrees on it
the Europeans have gone along with it
because the Europeans for the last 50
years have done nothing but go along
with US policy I mean they can't not do
that at some level when they finally do
you'll know we're in a truly different
world but the rest of the world Asia
China Brazil even Turkey which is not
particularly friendly with Iran at this
point I mean I mean you run through the
whole southern world and the Asian world
and it is a world that is against the
sanctions policy so this is this is it's
a complicated situation the book is
called the United States of fear Tom
Engelhardt is the author Haymarket books
published it thank you to the Arthur
Carter Center for journalism and thank
you for everybody for coming tonight
pick up the book